breaking news out of Saudi Arabia where
Fox's Brett Bear just sat down with
Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman who tells Brett that Iran getting
a nuclear weapon would be quote a bad
move with the potential to start a war
quote with the rest of the world here's
an exclusive bit from this interview
with Muhammad bin Salman airing tonight
on Special Report watch
are you concerned though Iran gets a
nuclear weapon about them getting a
nuclear weapon what we are concerned of
any country getting a nuclear weapon
that's a bad that's about the move you
don't need to get nuclear weapon because
you cannot use it even if you don't get
a nuclear weapon
any country used in equipment that means
they are
having a war with the rest of the world
the world cannot see another Hiroshima
if the world see 100 000 people did
that mean you are in a war with the rest
of the world so it's a useless effort to
reach a nuclear weapon because you
cannot use it if you use it
you gotta have a big fight with the rest
of the world if they get one will you if
they get one we have to get one
fascinating Special Report anchor Brett
Baer joins us now from Saudi Arabia
Brett good to have you with us a
fascinating interview and that is just
the beginning
Martha good afternoon your time it is
really fascinating there are historic
moments in this interview first of all
it's the first interview that his Royal
Highness the Saudi Crown Prince has ever
done in all English he answers every
question that I bring to the table in an
hour-long interview both a sit down and
a walk and talk portion we talk about
everything including his vision here I'm
on the Red Sea in the island of sindala
the first project in the neon project
they're building all kinds of things
trying to bring tourists in they answer
the questions he answers them about
human rights and 911 and Jamal khashoggi
about the world and all the leaders he
talks to about the U.S relationship and
take a listen to this about the
negotiations for normalization with
Israel
what would it take for you to agree to
normalize relations with Israel well
there is support from prison by the
administration to get to that point
for us the producing issue is very
important we need to solve that part and
we have a good negotiation let's
continue till now we're going to see
where it will go we hope that it will
reach a place that it will ease the life
of the Palestinians and get Israel as a
player Middle Middle East there were
reports that you had suspended in talks
no no that's that's not true not true
so you think if you were to characterize
it are you close
every day we get closer
that is significant and that will have
major repercussions around the Middle
East uh there was a report the other day
that the talks had been suspended
between Saudi Arabia and Israel this is
a big deal and it comes after this G20
deal for a rail and Port system with a
number of countries signing on that
really will change the face about how
things move here in the Middle East and
the U.S is a part of that we talk about
the relationship with the U.S we talk
about President Biden and he essentially
goes around the world with all the
leaders weighing in at all the different
hot spots I am telling you I've done a
lot of interviews in my life I have
never had this much news in one
interview
at the same time wow uh well we look
forward to seeing it tonight and you
know there's also been interesting moves
with China and Saudi Arabia and I look
forward to hearing more about that as he
you know sort of takes us around because
the dynamic with Saudi Arabia and where
their their shift is you know where the
gravitas is in terms of their
relationships with others is hugely
important
um you know with regard to President
Biden Brett he called uh MBS a pariah
after the khashoggi murder and the
investigation that was done here in the
United States did you get any sense that
that relationship is is thawing
you know I asked that specific question
first of all I asked a number of
questions about Jamal khashoggi and the
Fallout from it but in the follow-up to
that I asked about the relationship and
you're looking at the fist bump I asked
about the Pariah statement and then the
fist bump visit with a closed Fist and
then the recent G20 visit where he was
open Palm saying thank you for your
leadership and how that has changed uh
since that in the past five years
remember we're coming up on the
five-year anniversary of the Jamal
khashoggi killing he essentially said
that we have so many ties with the U.S
economically uh in in what they do
around the world that it is bigger than
one Administration he says the
relationship with President Biden is
good he has good back and forth and that
they are being helpful on the uh the
Israel negotiations he is very very
forthcoming and blunt and I'm telling
you that you know you talk to a lot of
officials who tiptoe around thing
because of sensitivities this is a very
matter-of-fact answer to a lot of tough
difficult complex questions that you're
really not going to believe yeah it's
fascinating and you know I want to play
this from uh from Benjamin Netanyahu the
leader of Israel talking about this
peace process being Within Reach at a
bilat today around the UN meetings watch
this
I think that under your leadership Mr
President we can forge a historic peace
between Israel and Saudi Arabia
and I think such a peace would go a long
way first to advance the end of the Arab
Israeli conflict achieve reconciliation
between the Islamic world and the Jewish
state
and Advance a genuine peace between
Israel and the Palestinians this is so
intriguing Brad you know the language
from the Crown Prince and from Netanyahu
but of course the big question is the
one that the Crown Prince brings up and
that is that the Palestinian issue is
very important to the Saudis so it did
I'm just into any sense of of what some
kind of agreement might look like
he didn't want to go into specifics I
did press them a couple different times
I did ask him can you make a deal with
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu he's 73 you're 38. he
essentially said yes I can but the
stipulations have to be right and his
concern for the Palestinians
particularly is significant he wouldn't
go into details because like many world
leaders they don't want to negotiate on
television but I'm telling you he shows
in our business we say a lot of leg as
far as answers
he does and around the world there are
major things major messages and the
shift in this country he talks about
significantly the transformation that he
is trying to see and how Saudi Arabia is
perceived as well as dealing with the
controversies in the past
yeah it's very interesting the changes
that have been made there in Saudi
Arabia in just recent years in terms of
freedoms for women are extraordinary
they can you know do things we take for
granted like going to a sports stadium
and driving a car and with some
regulations they can start businesses
and and all of those things Brad so I
look forward to hearing what he has to
say about that I'm also of course
curious and I know our viewers will be
as well about the energy situation it
feels like every time the White House
and the Biden Administration have tried
to get cooperation from Saudi Arabia in
terms of opening up the spigots a little
bit while price pressures have been
really onerous for Americans they really
haven't gotten much love back on any of
that
yeah he specifically asked him that
about oil production cuts the most
recent one and um he says that has
nothing to do with any other country he
says it doesn't have to do with American
politics it doesn't have to do with
Russia and Ukraine it has to do with our
sense of where we see the oil market and
stability long term he was pretty
specific this is a data guy he confirmed
that he is a computer gamer that's how
he blows off steam he likes to play
computer games he is in every detail and
he is very well aware of where Saudi
Arabia is positioned around the world
and clearly wants to step up more as a
world leader in a number of different
venues
yeah I am you know obviously there's
just so much to discuss with him and he
is this new generation of leadership
um you know we all remember when he
first came to his level of power there
there were a lot of leadership that was
basically you know held hostage in a
hotel in Saudi Arabia he really wanted
to shake up what he saw as the
corruption in the country you know I'm
curious what his you know thoughts are
on how all of that looks now
yeah and I specifically asked about the
past and what has happened even things
most recently Associated Press piece
about a man that posted criticism on
Twitter or now x uh who was sentenced to
die and he said yes and uh there are
things about our laws that need to be
changed he was very introspective he
said mistakes have been made this is a
country as I said in transition
religious conservatives obviously ran
the show for a long time radical Islam
was a problem he's been trying to root
that out but he acknowledges there are
still problems in the Kingdom sorry it's
a really windy night here on the Red Sea
uh in sandala there's a wonderful golf
course that's being built behind me
Robert trun Jones Jr I hope to play it
someday but it's uh it's quite quite
amazing to see the transition here but
we really talk about a lot on a lot of
different issues and I think think even
his staff was surprised how blunt he was
yeah it's refreshing to get you know
blunt answered I'm going to squeeze in
one more before I let you go on that
windy night the Abraham Accords
obviously uh there was a lot of progress
that was made under the Trump
Administration with reopening relations
between Israel and some of those
countries uh in some of the Arab
countries and there was a feeling at
that point that it was close in terms of
Saudi Arabia and Israel and you touched
on that in your first answer from him
did he give you any sense of the
difference between dealing with the
Trump White House and the Biden White
House
yeah I mean he talked a little bit about
that I actually asked him about Jared
Kushner I asked him about Investments
That Saudis have made
um listen we talked about a lot he says
that it's from Administration to
Administration he's still dealing with
America it is frustrating as a country
dealing with uh changing foreign policy
he said every four to eight years but we
deal with it because we are one-minded
uh he said we are you know focused on
our goals and by the way Martha those
goals keep shifting because he is
putting a lot of pressure on all these
Ministers of different places tourism
sports music all these different uh
ministers energy and they're giving them
specific data goals they're hitting them
and then setting new goals so his vision
2030 he talks about and I asked him
about what Saudi Arabia is going to look
like in 2040 and 2050. it's fascinating
and I guarantee you that this leader
despite all the criticism and
controversy is going to be around in the
Middle East for a long long time
fascinating Power Player and just just
to tease forward I know you also asked
him some questions that will be of
interest to the 911 families as well
Brett we will be watching every minute
of this on Special Report great to see
you in Saudi Arabia with this
fascinating interview with the Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman coming up
tonight on Special Report thanks Brett
we'll see you back here when you get
back
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else